das könnte der beginn des elektrischen
luftfahrt zeitalter sein
ein historisches datum das erste
vollelektrisch angetriebene
verkehrsflugzeug der welt in vancouver
hat seinen jungfernflug absolviert und
das in zukunft fliegen elektrisch wird
das ist gar nicht so utopisch klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt's übrigens mit
dem wissenschafts news jetzt auch
täglich als podcast die links spotify
und apple sind unten in der video
beschreibung 285 gramm co2 pro passagier
und kilometer produziert die
luftfahrtindustrie und ist damit laut
der eu umweltbehörde epa die
klimaschädlichste verkehrsbranche
überhaupt neben den verheerenden
auswirkungen auf das klima dürfte der
luftfahrtindustrie aber vor allem auch
der hohe kerosinpreis als einer der
größten kostenfaktoren sorgen bereiten
nicht nur die automobil sondern auch die
luftfahrtbranche steht also vor einem
bedeutenden wandel und das thema
elektrischer flugverkehr rückt immer
mehr in den fokus der traum vom
elektrischen fliegen von elektrischen
passagierjets liegt allerdings noch in
weiter ferne da viele technische
probleme noch nicht gelöst sind genau
wie bei elektroautos ist die geringe
effizienz der batterien noch die größte
baustelle aber auch wenn es noch dauern
wird bis der flugverkehr rund um den
globus elektrisch angetrieben wird ist
ein erster traum vom elektrischen
fliegen jetzt schon wahr geworden in
kanada startete das erste vollelektrisch
angetriebene verkehrsflugzeug der welt
der elektrische flugbetrieb in kleinere
maschinen auf kürzeren strecken könnte
also schon bald realität werden dass
pionier flugzeug das vom flughafen in
vancouver abhob und eine runde über den
fraser flusslauf drehte ist ein auf
e-antrieb umgerüstet das wasserflugzeug
vom typ dhc 2 devil and be war die
maschine war vorher mit einem kolben
sternmotor ausgerüstet der motor mit 750
ps sitzt in einer verlängerten nase des
fliegers und die batterien reichen für
eine halbe stunde planmäßiger flugdauer
und hat danach noch reserve power für
eine weitere halbe stunde flugzeit der
e-antrieb magni 500 wurde von der
ingenieursfirma knicks aus den usa
entwickelt laut dessen chef ganz husky
beweis der jungfernflug
das kommerzielle luftfahrt mit
elektroantrieb möglich sei und markiert
zitat den beginn des elektrischen
luftfahrt zeitalters am steuer der
maschine saß recknagel der chef des
unternehmens aber er möchte seine
gesamte flotte von etwa 40
wasserflugzeugen umrüsten er erhofft
sich davon auf teuren flugzeugtreibstoff
verzichten zu können um millionen an
wartungskosten einzusparen da
elektromotoren deutlich weniger wartungs
anfällig sind damit der antrieb in serie
gehen kann sind erst noch einige tests
notwendig er muss auf seine sicherheit
überprüft werden außerdem braucht der
motor noch eine genehmigung von den
behörden die scharfen auflagen
unterliegt flugmotoren müssen sehr viel
höhere erwartungen an die
zuverlässigkeit und sicherheit erfüllen
als etwa pkw antriebe da ein ausfall
oder eine entzündung des antriebs hier
noch verheerender ausfallen würde
mehrere hersteller arbeiten an konzepten
mit denen zumindest kleinflugzeuge mit
deutlich leiseren und kleineren elektro
antrieben ausgestattet werden soll das
größte problem stellt momentan vor allem
die stromversorgung an bord der flieger
da elektromotoren brauchen schon für den
flugzeug staat so viel energie dass sehr
große akkus verbaut werden müssen
die sind derzeit einfach noch viel zu
schwer um kommerzielle sinnvoll
eingesetzt zu werden aber wie an diesem
kanadischen beispiel zu sehen ist lösbar
denn eigentlich gibt es nur eine
herausforderung zu lösen und das ist der
hohe energieverbrauch und damit die
beschränkten kapazitäten der heutigen
batterien aber zwei dinge spielen dabei
eine wichtige rolle erstens der
energieverbrauch ist vor allem während
des starts hoch sprich die strecke die
geflogen werden soll spielt dann gar
keine so große rolle mehr
ist das flugzeug erst einmal oben ist
der energieverbrauch sogar relativ
niedrig also kein problem mehr für die
akkus zweitens akkus werden immer
leistungsfähiger und es ist möglich sie
immer schneller zu laden sind akkus also
in der lage eine flugstunde zu
ermöglichen und können danach im minuten
aufgeladen werden spielt die
akkukapazität kaum noch eine rolle die
dhc 2 könnte dann einen ganzen tag
fliegen wenn sie immer wieder schnell
aufgeladen werden könnte elektrisches
fliegen ist also gar nicht so utopisch
wie viele annehmen
die skandinavier scheinen die vorreiter
in sachen elektrischer flugverkehr zu
werden
norwegen plant bereits die
emissionsfreie luftfahrt für das jahr
2040 ab dann könnten die norwegischen
inlandsflüge ausschließlich mit strom
betrieben werden und auch schweden hat
große
der staatliche schwedische
flughafenbetreiber sevilla hat kürzlich
eine strategie für die elektrische
luftfahrt verabschiedet deren ziel ist
es alle zehn schwedischen flughäfen auf
elektrisch betriebenen flugzeuge
vorzubereiten bis etwa 2025 sollen sogar
die erste kommerzielle flug linie in
betrieb genommen werden bis 2030 strebt
schweden sogar an den inlands
flugverkehr komplett ohne fossile
brennstoffe zu meistern und bis 2045
soll dann auch der flugverkehr über die
stadtgrenzen hinaus elektrisch werden
der flugverkehr wird also in den
nächsten jahren wirklichkeit werden und
setzt taxis für kürzere strecken könnten
in zukunft in form von elektrischen
flugzeugen durch die lüfte fliegen wie
das ganze sogar ganz ohne piloten
funktionieren soll erfahrt ihr hier die
flug taxis kommen anklicken anschauen
und diesen kanal hier klickst zum
science fiction kostenlos abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran